Hi! In this video we're going to use Burp Intruder to find hidden subdomains that are
in scope but aren't explicitly linked from the initial set of domains you're testing.
You can use this to discover additional access points in a tax surface, such as internal
subdomains that really shouldn't be publicly accessible, or subdomains that have been forgotten
about and maybe aren't regularly updated. You should bear in mind this is a technique
that can only be used if the target domain has a wildcard DNS record.
Once you're ready, send a request for the main domain you're investigating to Burp Intruder.
For our test we're going to use portswigger-labs.net. Go to the Intruder tab and you'll see your
request. In the target field we're going to add a placeholder subdomain. I'm just going
to add X. To mark that as the payload position we just need to highlight the text and click
on Add. Now we can set up the attack details. Go to the Payloads tab and add your list of
potential subdomains. You can import your own list, but for this test choose either of the
directories built-in word lists. Click Start Attack. To help you identify which requests return
a different response, sort the results in order of length. You can see that the request sent
to staff.portswigger-labs.net has a different length. Although you can view the response in
the results, you can right click the subdomain you enumerated and choose Request in Browser,
In Original Session to copy a URL for the request. This particular URL will render a login page.
So, you can see that the request is to be a link to the request. This particular URL will
be a link to the request. This particular URL will be a link to the request. This particular
URL will be a link to the request. This particular URL will be a link to the request. This particular URL
will be a link to the request. This particular URL will be a link to the request. This particular URL
will be a link to the request. This particular URL will be a link to the request. This particular URL will be a link to the